lamello now hayward
hayward got talked out of that shot by
mcgee
three on the way is true simone jones
the cleveland native played at college
ball at southern cal she becomes the
fifth full-time female official this
season in the nba congrats to that
trio as meanwhile a drifting jumper by
terry rozier is true
sexton with the shot clock winding down
rozier stops fires got it
he's also leading the team in assists
triple double watch for junior
nine eight and seven rozier another
three
yep do you get hit with two turnovers in
that sequence if you're lamelo ball
we're gonna have to get a rolling on
that
rozier puts it up and in draws the foul
on dean wade
rozier says i want to scream bismarck
eventually he obliges
and rosiers ugly cans another three and
camp for the cavaliers the bench loves
it
rozier pressured by sexton got a screen
from biambo
and rozier has another sext and a
15-footer off a drummond screen
rebounded by cody martin
rozier now on osman feeling it rozier to
the bucket clears looking to close the
show
hayward off to martin extra pass rozier
he's been great in the second half
and that continues he needed to jump
start the offense
three on the way no good long rebound to
martin
rozier leaks out in on sexton took a
bump puts it
up and in and rozier has a chance for
three you want to give you they want to
defend the three
force you into the middle you got to
knock those shots down
was looking for biambo got batted back
to rozier who now has
34. that pass picked off by rozier
he has 36. wow
you have to turn keep the turnovers down
to bring the ball game
home rozier from three looking to keep
hope alive for the hornets and he does
[Applause]
rozier from deep what a night 42 and
remember he only had
six at the half 16 and a half in the
pre-season yes it's a steal yep
job floats it up and in and the
grizzlies forcing the turnover and
paying it off
and an early five-point lead two minutes
into the first very good basketball
player and will make big time plays
for the spurs team to give you an idea
of the rarefied air in which he plays
last year there's marant with a
beautiful finger roll in the lane
high volume drivers of the basketball in
our league as
morant finds an opening and fills it up
derozan is right up there retained
possession
for the grizzly shot clock at 10. morad
got derozan in the air floats it up and
in john morant
throws demar derozan his pick and pops
were all the way to the three-point line
now his pick and pop
is no further than the top of the key
marant with a runner
job san antonio
the thing for him is he gets up so high
you just go into a half jump you have no
chances wow
reverse he picked up earlier in the
quarter that was his third aldridge
with a misfire long lead pass morant
wham last year
averaged 27 a game against the grizzlies
did not play in orlando as morant hits a
runner
good deflection by kyle anderson
grizzlies force a turnover from san
antonio
john for three bango john miranda's
first triple
why do we need a shooter out right like
what am i going to teach these guys
well now with a younger team as a rant
with a sensational move to the rim
he's had a 10-point lead in the first
quarter
morant scooping and scoring through
traffic wanted a foul gotten on
pass aldridge a standstill three
rebound kyle anderson grizzlies without
a field goal in the last three and a
half minutes until that basket
by john morant
this birthday they got some young
players too partners they do
marantz we got us a young player
34 for moran 18 for aldridge and the
lead to 18
largest lead for san antonio morant
pulls up
and rings the bell again a new career
high for john morant with 36.
aldridge negotiating tough traffic
rebound brandon clark here comes morant
on the fly to the rim and in again
38 for morant to take two steps
to be able to get to nice save here by
valentine's
to be able to get to that last finish it
was one step and
going strong a 40 piece for
john moran minute and a half remaining
balls
digs it out clark on the pickup
marantz off the backboard and he slams
oh wow right because of defense demar
rosen takes it away look at this
throws off the glass to himself
i mean listen there may have been some
things that have not gone to grizzly's
way
but that man right there has kept it
interesting
the entire night look at that well the
other thing too is aldridge
didn't do anything in the first quarter
and they found other ways
as morant adds to his total 44 for josh
a lot of pressure on lower tonight so
guys are going to have to be alerted
where he's at
levine bumps trey young who banks it in
and a foul
area is off the screen from collins and
they do such a good job
in the two-man game between those two
guys you gotta you know once he comes
off that screen colin sets a good screen
it's a two-on-one break patrick williams
put that 225 pound
body on him first points of his
official career and there's trae young
knocking down a three he's gotta find
they gotta find trey young right now in
transition see he's already got down the
floor
and takes it all the way in for two more
you've got to pick him up full court yup
young the step back that's a three and
he knocks it down wow
collins left it short and it's run down
by trey young beating white and he sinks
up three
kobe's got to get that you got to hustle
him get that he came there's now watch
kobe
kobe's just going to kind of go after
the barely go after the ball and then
trey young comes back forward
and it hits a three you got to get this
ball if you're kobe white
you cannot allow trey young to come back
in and out so wendell carter jr is back
in with levine having to go to the bench
young cans another one this kid's
something else right now
[Applause]
white fighting through the screen trying
to stick with trae young who steps back
and
buries another one well and nothing you
can do about that
switch with marketing five to shoot
trey young into the pain wow counted and
a foul
wow it's too easy and it should be up um
right now larry is going to get beat it
doesn't matter what kind of defense he's
going to play trey young is too
quick so the bulls defenders the closest
defender
to lowry should be telling lowry send
him left
send him right so lowry knows if he gets
beat
maybe two three possessions at a time
but mix in some zone looks
oh levine got into the air gafford
wasn't looking for it chasing
herder who missed the layup where's
everybody at trey young just puts it
back in
[Applause]
young oh deep in the bag right there
that's that floating game he has more
he's got that little flip shot